okay
do you feel like you give girls more
wiggle room if they're if they're hotter
yes
you have do you know what it is you have
to be real with yourself though like you
gotta you gotta look yourself in the
middle so if someone's taking the piss
you're gonna be like come on man and I
think that's where people say it's ego
but that's where you gotta kind of
release say to yourself that's why if
you set yourself like those morals and
those ground rules for yourself then no
matter who steps in front of you if they
disrespect you then if disrespect you
you gotta kind of hold yourself
accountable to them but do they get away
with a bit more be honest uh then if she
was average if if it's black and white
then no no I mean okay so every guy
what's like every guy has an attraction
floor so I don't I don't know wait let's
let's say seven is yours so for girls
one girl's a seven and one to nine are
you giving the nine more wiggle room I'm
gonna give it a nine more wiggle room
yes
[Laughter]
wait what's what's up it's like the out
the sauce
okay okay so it's more to do with that
than just looks alone that's toxic
that's toxic relationships for you yeah
you know this is honestly
um do you think like like a nine gives
it better than that seven because I
personally think sevens give it way
better than the night
do they feel like they have to work
harder
maybe maybe I feel like the prettier you
are the less you kind of do in bed
because the ones that aren't as great as
the rest that they work they were it's
gym Antics we go into the nine to five I
think it's more to do with how crazy she
is is it how crazy or how beautiful she
is uh determined well that determines
what her passion yeah that's what they
usually say it's more to do with her
stability crazy in the real world is
linked to passionate in that world so
more to do with looks it's more
instability unstable women tend to be
more passionate it's the roller coaster
of emotions that they face yeah if you
get if you are an in like I'm an intense
person and so I've had intense
relationships prior you know so and
that's based on how you make them feel
like you've described as well but also
if they're a little bit crazy like but
in
intense relationships and toxic
relationships they're lit but obviously
they're not sustained they're not
sustainable yeah they're unsustainable I
mean like when you wake up and there's
like someone standing over with a knife
and you just I go aggravated
has that happened to you yeah yeah but
it was a different girl who tried to
push me downstairs
yeah but I'm like you're like five foot
you need to check
yeah everyone says that what do I do I
don't do what did you do I'm just
kidding what did you do I don't know
yeah probably to be honest I probably
aggravated her like I was but the thing
is I used to be a Savage I'm not you
know respectful mad man like that how
angry she was at that what's the reason
did you call the police
I actually just said look you what are
you doing you're gonna make me a
sandwich with that
but to be fairly you know what it is I I
don't I will say this though I haven't
um I used to not be very self-aware so I
used to do things and then see why
someone would get upset and think what's
that upset that she will actually hold
it nice yeah but I'm like I'm like I
just think oh she's just being crazy
about them but now you know your own red
flag yeah but when you start analyze it
yeah she's crazy I'm sorry there's no
excuse there's no exactly what is your
character beforehand as well yeah
there's no excuse me I mean but you
sometimes I think it's good to take
account you couldn't you can like drive
people to things you don't realize what
you're doing I think you can make people
crazy I think you can and like when you
look back
I think that is way too much holding a
knife that's extreme
I think you have to have it in them but
you as a person could definitely ignite
the worst side of a human being good
like that yeah I agree I agree I think
your ears are either crazy or you're not
and either have it in you or you don't
there's a baseline I've been in toxic
I've been in a toxic situation where I
very well could have acted crazy but
that's not my character I wouldn't do
that so you're either the type of person
to do that [ __ ] or you're not I don't
basically but the way I have girls ever
brought out the worst in you because I
know I've done it before I get into it
before I get into any situation I have a
look at myself and I say listen if it
gets Peak I'm walking the best thing to
do so grounded like that but that's yeah
I'm around I'm around all the time
there's no there's nothing you can't you
you need to look at it like this year
before I met you you were before I met
you're just an attractive woman and then
we got together and the feelings grew
and all this kind of stuff but I don't
need you in my life I didn't need you
before so I can still live without it
you know I mean so um yeah I'd like to
have that have that talk with yourself
though because otherwise you get lost in
the sauce and it's crazy and you might
do something stupid and then you might
be in jail or something like that and
she's moving on anyway it's done yeah
for real you might you might be in jail
yeah
it gets slower in some situations man
there was a an interesting scenario
though when I I quote someone with their
thumb trying to put my thumb
you know in those moments I'm not even
angry I'm just it's just you must be so
embarrassed exactly
you said that's standard yeah
but it's going through phone standard I
don't think
they always tried to Snoop and sometimes
I mean sometimes you can get baited out
but whatever yeah um yeah they always
have that inkling as well and if if they
there's nothing worse than a woman's
intuition she might not have any
evidence but her intuition is enough so
then she goes looking for the evidence
do you think
embarrassing if you had a business you
would do audits right yeah okay it's
only this whole it's the notion of a man
you know caring so much to look through
but I think I would say like this if you
felt like he was gonna you was with her
for a while and you weren't really and
you feel like something was is up
I understand why certain men do
personally I wouldn't just because I
don't even want to feel what's on that
side so if I feel something's up I just
walk I'm just like that now yeah but um
sometimes sometimes not that deep
especially like when you feel sorry like
really feel something for it you might
be thinking you know let me not make the
crazy part let me just see if it's
actually if it's not then babe I'm sorry
but then when you do because I've been
in that situation I actually came across
what I thought it was you do end up
going on the crazy side of it because
you end up feeding into what what you
originally thought yeah because deeply
like you could have found nothing and
you almost felt like Colombo you're like
yeah you got that you got that energy
now what like we're gonna do now and the
thing is if you find something if you do
look and you find something don't just
nag them like leaving it do something
yeah just you know I mean you wanna you
wanna keep the person around and then
just punish them I think modern women I
think they like being cheated on I swear
to God because the amount of girls
yeah because they never yeah but then
you could say about Modern Men because
they like the baddest [ __ ] I mean I
don't see it's interesting do you know
what's interesting especially with you
and like other girls that come on the
show whenever we talk as many of you
know I was just banned on Tick Tock and
we are demonetized on a daily basis on
this platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible